bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag
c'est l'été et donc le moment de prendre
le temps pour découvrir son territoire
saint quentin en yvelines offre quantité
d'activité grâce à la diversité et
richesse de ces lieux sport culture
détente
il y en aura pour tous les goûts et on
découvre le programme tout de suite
c'est parti
[Musique]
et
et vous que feriez-vous pendant votre
été saint quentinois je vais me détendre
au parc
moi j'aime bien me poser sur une
terrasse pour un petit café bronzé lire
un bon livre le trouve proche la nature
planer autour du canal
ces luttes est temps qu'on se repose et
fralon j'aime bien marché j'ai un petit
chien donc je marche buffet la piscine
et le vélodrome depuis les magasins
allaient à la base de loisirs la voie de
la balade et à défaut n'est pour les
enfants
yang lan d'activités là bas neil de
loisirs en effet regorge d'activités
pour toute la famille c'est le troisième
site touristique le plus visité d'île de
france 600 hectares de verdure le plus
grand étant de tout l'espace francilien
est une réserve naturelle c'est
l'endroit idéal pour profiter de l'été
c'est parti pour la visite
bienvenue sur l'île de loisirs une
réserve naturelle exceptionnelle classée
natura 2000
elle concentre espèces sauvages animales
et végétales et concilient préservation
de la nature et préoccupations socio
économique
sa multitude d'activités de plein air et
ses animations estivales en font le lieu
idéal pour profiter des beaux jours
voile golf kayak ferme pédagogique
séjour dans le village de yourtes et
tipis pique niques et barbecue jeux
d'eau les activités les plus diverses
sont proposées dans le plus grand espace
éducatif sportif et nature d'une de
france et l'été il s'agit de ne rien
manquer il y aura en particulier le
village sportif d'été qui étaient
organisés par par la région ile de
france donc c'est du 10 au 28 juillet
alors je vous cite quelques activités à
du badminton du beach volley
de l'équitation
du ventre i10 chaque année c'est plus de
huit cent mille visiteurs qui viennent
profiter des activités de lille donc
25000 personnes de 7 à 77 ans rien que
pour le parcours accrobranche à parcours
parmi les plus importants sur l'île de
france
autre succès du site
le parcours de golf il ya un public très
important pour le golf puisque au
travers de la société blue green qui
exploitent pour notre compte le golf de
l'île de loisirs avec 2 18 trous et un
parcours de six trous plus un practice
c'est quand même à peu près 60 mille
personnes soixante mille personnes à
l'année qui viennent jouer au golf sur
l'île de loisirs donc entre l'accueil de
la ryder cup en 2018
et cette offre de
golfique que nous avons sur l'île de
loisirs tout ceci est parfaitement
complémentaire et donc permet de dire et
d'accueillir un maximum de personnes
golf également tournée vers les enfants
le succès de lille est également due à
ses activités sans cesse renouvelée
depuis le mois de juin
le ski parc a ouvert ses portes sur
l'ancien site de la piscine à vagues
place à la nouveauté et à l'innovation
alors on y trouve aujourd'hui sac
activités viennent activités ainsi
derrière que l'activité goal c'est
vraiment fait pour tout public pour que
les gens qu'ils se rendent compte que le
boeuf est ouvert à tout le monde et que
tout le monde peut jouer
après on a un parcours de ce qu'on
appelle le site ikoko c'est un hybride
entre la patinette électrique le scooter
électrique
on a une piscine à bulles pour marcher
sur l'eau donc ça c'est les grosses
bulles de 2 mètres aussi qui sont faites
pour marcher sur l'eau qu'on s'amusait
ou si bien pour les ados que pour les
adultes
on a une volière de drones qui
complètement avec des filets de 12
mètres de haut et 1800 m² au sol et la
dernière activité la 5e et la cua carte
c'est le karting sur rose sur la pointe
du lac
et là c'est vraiment un karting
électrique qu'on a misé sur l'eau et qui
permet d'avancer entre 25 à 30 km/heure
sur l'eau l'entrée du ski parquet
gratuite l'achat de jetons permet de
pratiquer les diverses activités et de
se restaurer à la buvette
voilà où vous a tout dit qu'on a
d'autres projets pour l'été prochain dé
l'âge de garder le secret et pour
profiter pleinement des diverses
activités de livres voici quelques dates
à retenir les premiers et 25 juillet la
réserve naturelle nationale ouvre ses
portes aux initiés comme aux néophytes
afin de venir y observer 230 espèces
d'oiseaux dans un espace protégé
le 18 juillet de 10 heures à 17 heures
le comité départemental du sport en
milieu rural des yvelines vous invite au
disc golf pour les férus du frisbee les
17 18 et 19 juillet place au judo tour
initiation pour les petits et pour les
grands
pour les scientifiques en herbe rendez
vous sous le dôme de l'espace
événementiel
l'exposition itinérante et participative
r l'expo qui inspire s'installe jusqu'au
30 juillet sur l'île au programme
activités interactives pour tout savoir
sur l'air
si vous habitez l'une des douze connu
saint-quentinoise vous pouvez demander
une carte d'accès à l'accueil de l'île
de loisirs la communauté d'agglomération
offre cette carte d'accès crédité de
trois entrées véhicules gratuite
l'été c'est aussi l'occasion de se poser
pour s'ouvrir à la culture café
littéraire transat sur la terrasse du
canal contre en balade
tout un programme pour les médiathèques
les médiathèques à l'heure estivale dans
le cadre de l'opération partir en livre
les médiathèques investissent les parcs
les parviz les terrasses afin d'amener
les saint quentinois à la lecture
plusieurs rendez vous ont lieu tout
l'été pour le jeune public compteur et
bibliothécaires proposent des contes en
balade des déambulations et autres
chasses aux trésors
et puis la médiathèque du canal
accueille les lecteurs sur ses transats
et sous ses parasols
au programme jeu revu à lire les deux
pieds dans l'eau ou presque l'été c'est
aussi l'occasion de redécouvrir son
territoire saint quentin en yvelines
labellisée ville d'art et d'histoire
compte pas moins de 80 oeuvres d'art
disséminés dans les parcs et jardins
plusieurs rallyes pédestres sont
proposés entre nature urbanisme et
histoire le musée de la ville propose
trois rallyes thématiques pour explorer
le patrimoine saint quentinois un
premier parcours de plus de deux
kilomètres de guyancourt à montigny le
bretonneux entre ville et nature
ce parcours met en avant l'art dans la
ville et traverse le quartier de saint
quentin et le parc des sources de la
bièvre
le deuxième est basé sur le thème
promenons nous dans les années 70 un
parcours de 10 km d'elancourt amopa
entre l'urbain et le parfait
le dernier parcours est aussi le plus
long 13 km entre patrimoine art et
nature
il traverse les villes de guyancourt
montigny le bretonneux et voisins le
bretonneux un rallye très vert à travers
les sentes saint-quentinoise
téléchargeable en ligne c'est promenade
agrémentée de jeux de questions et
d'énigmes feront appel à votre sens de
l'observation et à votre réflexion
autre balade sonore cette fois aux
clayes-sous-bois équipé d'un casque
audio
la promenade écoutez voir vous guidera
sur plus de trois kilomètres au son des
témoignages d'habitants de la commune
alik des références historiques souvenir
une balade entre amis comme si vous
étiez
[Musique]
à pied à cheval ou à vélo le territoire
propose toutes sortes de parcours des
balades ludiques ou sportives avec ou
sans elin dans les parcs les ruses et
les forêts et à chacun son parcours
[Musique]
retour sur l'île de loisirs à trappes
pour jouer les explorateurs sur 3 km
grâce aux ballades énigme quarante et
une énigme quiz jeux de réflexion et
petits défis nous mènerons de la ferme
pédagogique jusqu'aux portes de la
réserve naturelle en passant par le
centre équestre des randonnées à
partager c'est l'idée du site vise au
rando sur lequel chacun peut partager
son parcours parmi lesquels une
promenade d'environ 7 km au départ de
villepreux jusqu'aux rues de gagny
n'hésitez pas à proposer votre parcours
préférés
[Musique]
en forêt de sainte apolline rechercher
les indices pour vous aider à résoudre
une énigme
un itinéraire proposé par le département
et cap orientation une enquête
accessible à tous
[Musique]
et puis au coeur du parc naturel
régional de haute vallée de chevreuse
plus d'une quarantaine de circuits sont
proposés randonnée pédestre vtt à cheval
en rollers et même accompagné de
poussettes l'itinéraire grange de port
royal est accessible en vtt et sillonne
magny les hameaux et voisins le
bretonneux un circuit notre bois champs
et patrimoine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cinéma de plein air séjour en bord de
mer centre d'équitation ou encore place
j'étais levin saint-quentinoise propose
une multitude d'activités durant la
période estivale
n'hésitez pas à vous rendre sur les
sites des diverses communes pour vous
informer
je vous souhaite un très bel été après
bientôt
ciao
[Musique]